you better call the national guard
i don't see that hey what's up we can't
kick their ass they need help they gonna
say no
doubt that's three weeks in a row i'm
like oh this is reminding me of like
back in the day
oh you already got a ring it's our turn
bro
we'll see y'all next year welcome to the
playoffs baby
hey these games late for everybody's
game for the elite just give it all you
got
this is going to be awesome tom brady
patrick holmes
generation against generation oh this is
huge
hey we're on the beach today huh huh
you're on the beach man you see it huh
see us our wish we were in tampa oh
hey we worked all year for this moment
right here play together
playing fast let's dominate a football
game
ribs are done beer's in the fridge
buck's
[Music]
this is it right here this is it right
here
ain't no bigger stage than this man
what's up with you this could be one for
the ages
oh i see what you did there this is a
match-up that we're going to be talking
about for a long time been here before
baby do what we do
one play at a time do what we do this is
why you want to play the game your whole
life though
for this moment right here you got to
take advantage of the opportunity now
hot diggity dog that was tight that
ought to get you a little fired up
you're good here's the approach toe hits
leather
super bowl 55 is underway
yeah okay all day five
sir yes sir
[Applause]
great defense on the back end
49 yard attempt by pucker and he's got
it three nothing kansas city
go boys get it we're one plate at a time
huh let's go tommy
the bucks or the red zone
here's brady's pass it's gronkowski
the biggest tandem for touchdowns now
in post-season history he fired the damn
cannons
that's my dog robbie g big g that's the
big g
and the kansas city chiefs are
struggling on third down
watch my arms just gonna get pressure
and that is costly
you kill that edge baby let's
and the buccaneers knocking on the door
again leading seven to three
long count by brady they fake on the run
they throw it left wide open
knocked away at the last second they
went to joe hague
that's why he's an offensive tackle he's
gonna catch it fall he'll know
he don't know gotta catch a fall fourth
down all right go for it man
why not bucks you're gonna go for it on
fourth down d
you need touchdowns when you have the
chance to get in ronald jones jr
push back did he get across the goal
line touchdown no
no no yeah let's go
what's happening turnover is so big in
these games
brady standing tall pass knocked down
intercepted off the deflection
pending the penalty that was in these
chief secondary interception on third
and four
wiped out they're going to call javarius
ward with a holding penalty
defense is playing great let's score for
him right here play action fake brady
looking
[Applause]
hey good time to do it yeah i'm like oh
this is reminding me of like back in the
day
let's go av let's go lindy come on d
buccaneers line up at the one yard line
10 seconds on the clock
brady play action fake looks toward the
right though so that touchdown
that's why you don't get scared baby
very unfortunate undisciplined play by
the chief's defense
[Applause]
it's a buck's life over here baby i
didn't score because i wanted you to
score
robbie g mike i love not even third
oh that's a physical ass drive you see
lenny on that drive
that's four touchdowns i'm gonna turn
now oh go get it now
why not four
[Music]
yo he is a magician i'm convinced
mahone's
is unbelievable trying to do anything to
help this team and taking a huge
shot keep fighting babies keep fighting
turn over it's over
turn over and it's over sunny side
there's the snap mahomes running to his
right lookout he may run my home's
it's our turn bro we'll see y'all next
year
congratulations you deserve it man
thanks brother so happy for you
way to go
you're saving up for the super you take
it out
hold on baby
we're the champions of the world tom
brady you are the man you are the goat
the greatest of all time we won man
do you know what that means
people keep calling me bandwagon does
this look like
bandwagon gear to y'all yeah
sammy just won the super bowl chad what
are we gonna do gosh i am
i am a wave of emotion i'm getting dizzy
from spinning disney world
and how long we've been bucks fans since
day one the dream sickle day is based